when a student audits a class aside from
looking at the technique and the teacher
should they also be surveying sort of
the mood of the class what the other
peers are like there so they can see if
there are fit I think so I think the
reason to take an acting class and
whether it's in Hollywood or in New York
or anywhere in the world is also to join
a community you know and to me always
the atmosphere of an acting class is
informed by who teaches it who's the
leader of the class who's the captain
the same thing like a movie set you know
who's running the ship and if that
person is you know person that's
creative and fun then it's gonna be fun
and if the leader of the boat is you
know somebody that's afraid somebody has
a lot of ego it's a way that's you know
led by arrogance then it's gonna be a
tough ride there was that saying in
corporate America sort of it rolls
downhill
you know I'm cleaning it up a bit but so
it's similar to any type of a group
setting where there's a leader a teacher
so it would be the mood of the teacher
sort of sets the tone absolutely yeah
what was Ben aware I mean I've taken
many classes where you know the mood is
competitive which okay you know and
that's that's the world the world is
competitive but within that I think you
want to forge them a lot alliances I
mean my classes for instance I have had
several so many several so many students
that have formed friendships and
collaborations that have lasted for
entire decades students have formed
theatre companies together and they have
made movies together and written scripts
together and that's the way it should be
you should be able to walk into a class
and find people that you can be creative
with
you